hélène budget ti paul journet luc
ferrandez bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir je
vous fais tout de suite à entendre
monsieur dubé ce n'était pas avec nous
en début d'émission il dit l'heure est
grave l'intro le monde des hôpitaux et
ceux qui pensent qu'on peut alléger les
mesures oh là là vous êtes dans chat on
écoute et on est en train de parler deux
protocoles de priorisation de thé je
vous le dis la situation dans les
hôpitaux si les gens n'ont pas compris
en ce moment qu'on est rendu au bout du
rouleau là on est rendu vraiment au
maximum de lait là c'est qu'on a pu
tirer une alimente encore douze mille
personnes dans le réseau qui tienne ça à
bout de bras puis vous pourriez être la
première personne la prochaine personne
que besoin d'aller à l'hôpital soit pour
le coc du doubs soit pour un bras cassé
fait je comprends que déjà qu'ils sont
tannés mais penser au réseau pensé à
tout personnel qui tresse à bout de bras
depuis 22 mois je pense que les gens
vont peut-être prendre un peu de recul
mais dire oui on aimerait ça ouvrir mais
attendons un petit peu vous avez compris
que repas d'ouverture bientôt et
d'ailleurs ce qui a fait dire au député
vincent marissal du québec solidaire il
hante les envolées jovialiste de
françois legault et la situation
catastrophique des clips pas christian
dubé les québécois ne s'y retrouve plus
les chiffres sont là effectivement ont
la tête dure ya beaucoup de
spécialisation hélène est ce que
est ce que ce plaidoyer là et efficace
encore d'après je ne sais pas je pense
que les gens sont un peu mêlé passez-moi
l'anglicisme j'ai un peu l'impression du
good cop bad cop monsieur legault qui
nous parlait de la lumière au bout du
tunnel et monsieur dubé est entrain
essentiellement de nous dire que cette
lumière là bas c'est peut-être celle du
train qui s'en vient
on a de la misère à s'y retrouver mais
la réalité c'est que il ya personne que
de boule de cristal pour nous prédire la
situation pour pouvoir nous dire regarde
on fait tout ça et dans deux trois
quatre semaines quel que soit le délai
on va pouvoir relâcher les mesures et on
se gèrent encore beaucoup à la petite
semaine je dirais même à la petite
journée et en cette matière le je ne
suis pas certaine qu'il put s en aller
autrement
quand le
guide de priorisation été mis en place
pas exécuter encore de la docteure au
pas terni nous disait tout à l'heure ça
va vouloir dire si on arrive là qu'on va
tourner les coins ronds et son
expression qu'on va dire aux gens les
douze ans plus tôt que normalement on
fait alors c'est dramatique où seules
épaules
c'est plus dramatique que non et puis je
sais que la semaine dernière on
entrevoyait un possible pic puis on dit
que peut-être bonne nouvelle ça va
redescendre et la seule certitude les
projections sont très hasardeuse la
seule certitude qu'on a c'est que la fin
de semaine dernière était censée être la
pire en un instrument on actuellement un
ralentissement de la croissance dès que
dans les hospitalisations et ça c'était
avant le retour à l'école donc on avait
notre pire fin de semaine et on ajoute
un facteur de risque donc ça allait mal
et ça risque d'aller encore pire ou à
tout le moins sa réseau prend un petit
bouc que ça s'améliore donc je pense que
ce qui nous a été présentée aujourd'hui
était à la fois beaucoup plus réaliste
et déprimant que ce qu'ont laissé
entrevoir la semaine dernière l'udc
mais moi je fais une hypothèse me
demande je pose une question de fond je
me demande si monsieur le goût ne l'a
pas fait
ne pas adopter un modèle de gestion à la
floridienne c'est à dire
puisque on n'arrive pas à réduire le
nombre de morts parce que les gens qui
sont morts sont des gens qui ont souvent
le hall et beaucoup vu le des personnes
très âgées qui ont beaucoup de koboko
mordus de khobar beat it et donc des
problèmes qui précède celui de la
qu'ovide grave ou alors déjà que sont
pas vaccinés et donc d'accepter un
nombre de morts plus élevé pourrait
ouvrir l'économie pour dire maintenant
on est au neuf on avait tout axé nation
qui est extraordinaire on a eu des
mesures les parmi les plus dures au
monde et on n'est pas arrivé à réduire
le nombre d'abord alors il en va on va
en prendre note on va ouvrir un peu
d'économie on va notamment permettre de
rater las et le reste ça va dépendre du
vaccin vous êtes vacciné vous avez des
chances de vous en sortir vous n'êtes
pas vacciné vous avez moins de chance de
vous en sortir vous avez des problèmes
de comorbidité vous avez moins de chance
de vous en sortir parce que eh bien là
on a déjà parlé à plusieurs chemins du
cias panel des statistiques parce que
tout découle des chiffres dont on n'ose
analyse des cours de ce qu'on nous
présente donc d'hospitalisation 3400
veut revoir le tableau oui une vraie
augmentation de 36 et soins intensifs
289 mais là ce matin docteur marqué dans
la presse et de 10 ce que le bien dire
c'est oui mais les décès l'a 89 décès
convoi il ya beaucoup de cd c log sont
pas décédées monaco vide il avait la
coved ils sont décédés d'autres raisons
comorbidités etc donc c'est ça qui fait
que parfois on a envie de regarder le
verre à moitié plein d'autres sont là
malheureusement leurs gardes à moitié
vide
oui effectivement c'est vrai mais sur
cette question là que lieu qui abordait
le modèle floridien peut-être que dans
les mots c'est ce que l'on dit mais
c'est quand même pas ce que l'on fait
encore sur le terrain oui ok l'école
réouvre mais les commerces sont encore
fermés les salles de spectacles de le
sonder soumis à toutes sortes de
contraintes dans les rassemblements et
cetera dans les faits on a encore une
gestion quand même très serré de cette
de cette pandémie ce que je trouve
je faisais pas de jugement parce que
j'ai pas évident mais moi je joue avec
le feu c'est très serré effectivement
moi ce que je trouve quand même
intéressant dans ce plan d'eau de deux
offres de reprise à sion des
hospitalisations qui nous dit qu'ils
aient présenté et d'ailleurs vous aviez
un éviter plutôt avoir fait une citation
dans un des reportages qui mentionnait
un médecin c'est que on nous dit qu'il
faut pas être repensé les soins que l'on
à un colon qu'on leur prodigue poète sur
le pilote automatique finalement et s'il
ya quelque chose qu'on va peut-être
apprendre de cette pandémie c'est
peut-être ça c'est de repenser notre
approche aux soins notre système de
santé il est beaucoup basé là dessus on
soigne souvent sans trop se poser de
questions jusqu'au dernier souffle et
peut-être qu'on devront arriver là
arriver avec une approche un peu plus
critique par amanda qu'est ce qu'elle
soit on prodigue époque et donc en ce
sens je trouve que ce plan là il est
inquiétant pour ce qu'il nous dit en ce
moment de l'état de la situation mais il
amorce peut-être une réflexion qui
devrait se poursuivre bien au delà de la
pandémie oui c'est un peu comme quand
docteur au paternel nous dit on devra
pour n'est pas formé comme ça il le
personnel en santé n'est pas formé comme
ça on devra tourner les coins ronds
peut-être agir différemment il peut
aussi avoir du bon là dedans
oui baseball on avance à ce qu'on évite
le pire cette réflexion là vient pas du
politique lui serait un parallèle avec
la flore et de gouverneurs
qui se faire plaisir à son électorat
puis au lobby du milieu des affaires
dans ce cas ci les deux choses dont on
parle rapidement le retour à l'école
c'était entre autres malgré tout des
controverses recommandé par les
pédiatres et pour scier de nouvelles
façons traiter les patients à l'hôpital
beth et la ffb ce qu elle même qui a
lancé le débat et c'est sa façon de
trouver comment vivre avec le virus en
milieu hospitalier et dans les soins
dont on accepte de ne pas être parfait
de laisser entrer en effet plus le virus
à l'hôpital d'abord peut-être un peu
moins de patients un retour plus rapide
des du personnel soignant parce qu'on se
dit qu'il faut pas vouloir est tellement
parfait avec les soins prodigués aux
patients atteints de la côte est moins
parfait
c'est ce qu'on veut c'est ce qu'on dit
il il faut il faut apprendre à
enlever de nos têtes le risque zéro et
être moins parfait c'est ce qu'a dit ce
qu'on dit oui c'est vraiment
l'organisation des soins en milieu
hospitalier puis là on tombe vraiment
dans une question qui relève en entrant
de l' expertise de la fmsq mais vraiment
serpillon qui ont lancé la réflexion
puissant blake contente de ce qui était
annoncé aujourd'hui bon le
j'imagine que ça va être une réflexion
très nuancée parce que ce qu'on
reprochait au système de santé avant la
pandémie c'est justement d'accepter trop
peu deux patients l'hôpital et de les
renvoyer trop tôt il ya des des
poursuites à n'en plus fainéants contre
les hôpitaux ici comme dans les autres
pays ici on est au canada avec l'irlande
et israël le pays qui a le moins de lits
par habitant est de loin c'est à dire
que la france en a deux fois plus que
nous le japon trois fois plus que nous
donc on a un modèle où il ya déjà très
peu de lits où on fait ça on fait de la
médecine ambulatoire on laisse les gens
le moins possible à l'hôpital et
lorsqu'on nous dit ce qu'on va les
laisser en coin alors je veux bien que
par la pandémie on soit obligé de faire
ça de france pour une éducation très
large pour savoir est ce que c'est la
seule solution est-ce qu'on est assez de
lits est ce qu'on doit poursuivre ce
après la pandémie les questions sont
posées oui et d'ailleurs beaucoup de
voix se lèvent en rapide à la question
était posée aux mines et sont
aujourd'hui est ce que dans tout ça
l'élément positif c'est qui va avoir une
réflexion d'une réflexion il ya eu
beaucoup mais une réorganisation
forcée du système de santé
oui en fait le mentionner mais c'est
comme un virage ambulatoire
2.0 qu'on nous présente aujourd'hui
autres qu'on nous laisse envisager il y
avait une statistique mode qui a frappé
mon imagination quand on nous dit que
13% des personnes hospitalisées en ce
moment sont défense le terme c'est des
hospitalisations alternative entre des
hospitalisations de gens qui n'ont plus
vraiment besoin des soins aigus des
plateaux techniques claque comme on dit
des hôpitaux alors treize courses ans
c'est beaucoup que font-ils encore à
l'hôpital alors on vise à ramener ça à 5
pour ça on dit qu'on libère est
peut-être quelques six ans 600 lits
supplémentaires qui subitement serait
disponible mais quand même pourquoi 13%
c'est beaucoup et on en a parlé je pense
la semaine dernière on mentionnait par
exemple que les sachets celle des et les
rpa refusent parfois le retour de
certains patients qui était à l'hôpital
pour d'autres problèmes et qui par
ailleurs ont eu la qu'ovide on veut pas
les recueillir les accueillir à nouveau
parce qu'on n'a pas requis qui le
déclenche une éclosion et ben moi ce que
j'ai hâte de voir c est ce qu'on va
pouvoir forcer dans ce nouveau plan les
chsct et les rp un axe aptc graciant là
ça va nécessiter beaucoup de
coordination
panquébécoise tour de table rapide sûr
parce que vous parlez du modèle
floridien qui l'extrême loué comme dit
paul jouent aux cow boy davantage mis un
modèle en europe en france le modèle en
grande bretagne où on a décidé cette
expression la nounou dessus mais ça
reste vrai de vivre avec le virus
mais quand on a autant la conférence de
presse palais l'udc c'est pas demain
matin qu'on va annoncer la réouverture
de plusieurs lieux
n'ont absoluement effectivement
ils ont rendu les commentaires rapides
non puis lentement les os en train
d'essayer de colmater des fuites du
réseau de la santé et j'ai on pourrait
souhaiter que la pandémie nous force à
faire une réflexion plus large sur
l'administration des soins de santé mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est moins ce
qu'on fait c'est moins une réflexion
qu'une réaction constante on voit que
nos finances on voit comment on peut
régler les problèmes à court terme c'est
comme si on n'avait jamais les moyens
entre autres en personnel
de pouvoir essayer de réfléchir
de patrons parlent sur le long terme et
pour répondre à votre question parce que
son nom n'est pas encore rendue produite
au contraire on se prépare plutôt à la
prochaine étape que l'on appréhende
celle du protocole de triage même si on
n'est pas encore rendu là plus que
je faisais les empêche pas je posais le
parallèle avec la floride pour une autre
raison pied précis c'est que depuis
quelques jours on a le même nombre de
morts par habitant que la floride au
total de l'amendé milan ferait dans
notre deux fois plus que nous mais en ce
moment dans les derniers jours on a le
même nombre de bord avec tous les
efforts on a fait des efforts énormes
comparer la floride notamment mais pas
encore par au monde entier et donc la
question se pose à dire est ce que ces
efforts la porte des fruits à ce moment
ci à cause d'un micro à cause du
vieillissement de la population à cause
de la de la comorbidité est ce que le
fait d'ouvrir une pause ouvrir
l'économie autant d'impact que ça sur le
nombre de morts pour l'instant on n'a
pas la réponse à cette question est
d'ailleurs docteur boileau a dit on
travaille fort en coulisses parce que fo
avant cette réponse là parce que
qu'entre temps qu'on n'aura pas ça
réponse leclerc est ce que par exemple
on calcule mal est plus que d'autres ici
la question que vous posez de plus en
plus de gens vont se poser c'est à dire
est ce qu'on fait tout ça pour
finalement avoir le même bilan que la
fleurette que paris que l'on qu'ailleurs
mais mais il faut faire attention parce
que toutes les populations comme comme
le mentionnait ne sont pas pareils ça
dépend de notre âge on est vieux plus
jeune plus sa santé et donc les
comparaisons sont difficiles et donc il
devient impérieux de dire est ce que son
père ne pas enfermer l'économie ce qu'on
ne saura jamais parce qu'on peut jamais
faire deux scénarios parallèle c'est si
on n'avait pas fermé l'économie est-ce
que ça serait pas encore pays évidemment
ok on va changer de sujet roche whipple
en 2d pour clore sa si vous voulez
mais justement si on ne fait pas si on
ne fait pas ça pour rien et malgré tout
ça va aussi mal ici qu'ailleurs ça veut
dire que si on ne faisait rien ça serait
pire est donc pourquoi ça serait pire
ici qu'ailleurs mais si la réponse est
positive pour le québec ce sont des
hypothèses effectivement ok monsieur
autour on écoute ça qui dit que les
libéraux par grand froid dans quelques
mois vont fermer le robinet du pétrole
et on prend du show fonds propre et
conduire vous avez y ait un bon texte
pas là dessus ce matin on est content
qu'il plus déconnectés hélène est ce que
vraiment les libéraux dans du mois
veulent couper le robinet du pétrole
j'espère parce que ma chauffent au gaz
ici faire écouter ce clairement monsieur
guilbeault ville a oublié un mot dans
cette entrevue il disait qu'il allait
abolir les subventions aux énergies
fossiles 6 18 mois il a fait l'élite du
mot subventions et donc les
conservateurs se sont amusés à le
prendre au mot et voilà il va faire
disparaître toute l'énergie nous allons
tous mourir de froid c'est évidemment
d'une très grande malhonnêteté
intellectuelle et le fait que monsieur
au tout le jour dans ce jeu ça démontre
que il ne sait pas vraiment comment
crampes et son leadership ou alors il
nous prend pour des idiotes épaules ou
alors il est prêt à dire n'importe quoi
pour une campagne de financement mais je
pense que les hypothèses d'hélène et
c'est là ne s'excluent pas au contraire
tout ça puisque la personne qui sèment
la division en ce moment aucun de
séverine autour parce que s'il est
sérieux et enfin prouver qu'il ne l'ait
pas ici veut vraiment tendre vers la
carboneutralité ben on ne peut pas
continuer à produire de plus en plus de
pétrole et pour lui de plus en plus tout
en promettant de polluer moins ce qu'il
faut c'est avoir un peu lent pour les
armes et essayer de rallier les
provinces de l'est aux autres provinces
avec un plan commun pancanadien pour
réduire les émissions tout en aidant les
personnes qui vont être affecté par ça
dans les dents le secteur pétrolier le
35 ans et willow tout parle à sa base on
se rappelle que au lendemain de
l'élection en septembre sa base de
beaucoup reproché d'avoir reconnu la
validité d'une taxe carbone d'avoir
reconnu la nécessité de garder déficit
pendant dix ans et d'abord le troisième
point je m'en souviens pas il n'échappe
à l'instinct mais le sabbat je lui en
voulaient beaucoup d'avoir fait un
virage centriste alors les profitent
d'une journée froide pour parler à sa
base pour dire je suis encore là pour
défendre l'économie de l'alberta et le
pétrole de l'alberta de la saskatchewan
point final demain cette histoire là
n'aura pas de suite parce que elle elle
n'a pas de prise dans le respect lyon
n'est plus à des promenades
merci beaucoup à vous trois bandes
soirée merci au revoir merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne i cirdi
oh